las negociaciones para ratificar el
acuerdo comercial se habían estancado en
determinado momento uno de los motivos
habría sido la desconfianza que generaba
para Europa el gobierno de Jair
bolsonaro no que llevó a niveles récord
la deforestación de la amazonía ahora
con nula da Silva en el poder Podemos
esperar entonces que realmente se
concrete para fin de año este acuerdo
Santiago Buenas tardes realmente es muy
auspicioso concretarlo a fin de año la
verdad es que el acuerdo ha recibido
muchísimas observaciones no solo de
Brasil sino de los otros integrantes del
mercosur en esta etapa recordemos Cómo
fue este acuerdo en el 2019 Argentina
Brasil Francia Alemania suscribieron un
acuerdo que fue anunciado en la
catorceava Cumbre de la f20 No saca
luego de todo esto este la verdad es que
el tema se se complicó bastante para los
para los dos lados no de alguna forma el
acuerdo nunca fue formalizado del todo
nunca fue cerrado No no tuvo una
revisión jurídica para nada Pero además
no fue ratificado por ninguno de sus
parlamentos hoy América del Sur recibe
los cuatro integrantes del mercosur
Argentina Brasil Paraguay y Uruguay
reciben una carta por parte de la Unión
Europea que En definitiva significa
un una comunicación unilateral no es
negociada donde se intenta
de alguna forma hablar de los
certificados de origen geográficos
ambientales y hasta de ADN por parte de
los exportadores lo que ha logrado que
Brasil haya decaído en su en su voluntad
de seguir con esto adelante y que
Argentina también se haya quejado mucho
con el tema del sistema de patentes hoy
por hoy tendríamos que pensar Santiago
que estamos en una etapa muy difícil de
que esto pueda salir este año o el año
que viene de concretarse qué implicaría
para las partes
hoy en la Unión Europea tiene tratados
ya tlc con chile y con México que serían
los países que ella va a visitar ahora
sería una un acuerdo serían acuerdos
espectacular en cuanto al aumento de lo
que podrían ser las exportaciones de un
lado y del otro no obstante en la propia
Unión Europea existen voces discordantes
se da en Francia se dan en Irlanda donde
de alguna forma los productores los
productores Rurales de los productores
de fruta
de agro se quejan de que con un con la
producción brasilera y la Argentina en
el tema de la soja serían ellos poco
competitivos parecería que esto va va a
ser un poco más largo de lo que se
piensa en especial Porque la Unión
Europea pone mucho hincapié en lo que
dio a llamar el pacto verde del cual
Brasil no va a poder cumplirlo y me
parece que Argentina también ahora desde
su creación el mercosur ha pasado por
etapas muy diferentes no Dependiendo los
presidentes de cada país en cada momento
de la historia Qué lugar ocupa hoy el
mercosur en la escena comercial
internacional
justamente Santiago es muy buena
pregunta la verdad es que el mercosur ha
sufrido muchísimos problemas hoy por hoy
el mercosur es un sistema que no que no
tiene de alguna forma nada que pueda
trabajar sobre las controversias no es
un sistema aduanero perfecto no es un
sistema migratorio tampoco perfecto
entre los cuatro países parecería muy
raro que una Unión muy perfecta como la
puede ser la Unión Europea encaje con
una Unión muy imperfecta como lo que es
el mercosur no es culpa de la Unión
Europea en este caso es culpa de los
cuatro países latinoamericanos que no se
han puesto de acuerdo no tienen nadie
que de alguna forma cate totalmente las
reglas que se habían puesto en su
momento y En definitiva subsisten
sistemas dentro del mismo sistema la
realidad de la zona franca de manaos la
realidad de la zona franca de Tierra de
Fuego la realidad de la zona franca de
Montevideo Y en especial las líneas
fronterizas entre el Uruguay y Brasil
donde hay mucho frío o lo que sucede
entre Paraguay y Brasil son realidades
que conspiran totalmente con lo que
sería una Unión aduanera como la que
tenemos en Europa que es una Unión
aduanera inmigratoria de de de
proporciones